Дим над полями. Дим у легенях.
Горять поля, ліси, селища.
Рання весна та золота осінь в Україні традиційно перетворюється на сезон спалювання листя,
а разом з ним - й інших відходів.
У 80% відсотках випадків, за даними ДСНС, пожежі в лісах починаються не в самих лісах,
а на полях та городах, де селяни спалюють опале листя, гілки, бадилля.
Це все б горіло. І це все лише з одного будинку, з одного домогосподарства.
Анастасія Мартиненко разом з іншими активістами селища Хотів у передмісті Києва
вирішили власними силами боротися з невмирущою традицією селян
спалювати непотріб і труїти все навколо.
І це попри те, що цього року штрафи за спалювання стерні в межах
населених пунктів для громадян збільшили в рази -
зі  170 до трьох-п'яти тисяч гривень.
Штрафи не працюють. Перевірено багато разів.
Бачу, що палять, дзвоню, бачу приблизно адресу на мапі, вираховую, приїздить поліція.
Вони  виписують протокол, він іде до сільради, там створюється адмінкомісія,
яка вирішує, чи стягувати ці кошти з громадянина чи ні.
Вони можуть вирішити, що ні, бо дуже часто ті, хто спалюють, самі є депутатами сільради.
Замість спалювання вони пропонують селянам альтернативу.
Агітують, щоб люди поступово збирали свої відходи, аби потім усе разом вивезти на спеціальний майданчик.
Активістам вдалося домовитися із сільрадою про машини для збору сміття і навіть
про виділення земельної ділянки під ці відходи - для компостування листя.
Вважається, що якщо спалити це все, то буде попіл, який нібито дуже корисний для ґрунту.
Проте насправді, якщо це закомпостувати, от це буде дійсно найкорисніше для ґрунту.
"Не пали - компостуй". Ця екологічна ініціатива з’явилася в Україні в березні.
І одразу стала популярною. За принципом "не пали-компостуй" вирішили
жити понад 200 громад по всій країні.
Проект започаткували в ПРО ООН, разом з партнерськими організаціями.
Громадам дали доступ до супутникових даних Європейської космічної агенції, вони відкриті,
і громади моніторять пожежну ситуацію на своїх територіях.
Також провели семінари, як правильно компостувати листя
і як боротися з паліями.
Громади охоче підхопили ідею і доповнили її своїми "ноу-хау".
Наприклад, є громади, які наділили повноваженням інспекторів з благоустрою
виписувати штрафи, тобто не лише екоінспекція може це робити.
Наприклад, створюють велозагони із запобігання пожежам.
Сідають на велосипеди, їдуть гасити пожежу раніше за будь-кого іншого.
Є громади, що призначили відповідальних за кожну вулицю,
які проводить роботу з тими, хто постійно палить.
Близько половини таких спалювань у ДСНС, поліції або екоінспекції не фіксується.
Тож, селян не сильно налякало підвищення штрафів.
Мовляв, "наші діди спалювали і ми будемо".
Не замислюючись над тим, якої шкоди завдають цим довкіллю, оточуючим та самим собі.
У першу чергу людина, яка стоїть і палить багаття, сама вдихає дим,
СО, СО2 та інші канцерогени, які впливають на респіраторну систему людини
і часто можуть привести до загострення хронічних хворіб.
Багато людей скаржаться. А на великому рівні цей вогонь шкодить екології.
Чорна сажа  пришвидшує танення льодовиків.
Здавалося б, я спалив купу сміття, але, по факту, це,
може бути винесене в атмосферу і перенесено аж туди.
Як повідомили DW в Держекоінспекції, відколи підвищили штрафи в квітні,
в Україні було виписано 430 протоколів.
Сума накладених штрафів у порівнянні з аналогічним періодом минулого року
збільшилася майже втричі - приблизно 400 тисяч гривень.
Щоправда, спіймати паліїв на гарячому майже неможливо,
каже волонтер-пожежник з Борисполя Андрій Макаров.
Саме таким, як він, потім доводиться усувати пожежі, які виникають внаслідок підпалу листя чи стерні.
Підпалювали стерню навколо Борисполя. У нас і так все постійно там горить,
машин не вистачає, всі на виїздах. Вони палять, займається сарай.
З сараю - на будинок. За цю весну лише в нас було 3-4 таких випадки.
Я не знаю, логічному поясненню це не піддається.
Можливо, на зло роблять, щоб навколо людей потравити…
Ситуація може поліпшитися, якщо в Україні затвердять так званий
електронний протокол реагування на пожежі, коли супутникові дані або
відеозйомки тих же активістів стануть офіційною підставою для складання протоколу.
Відповідний законопроєкт нині обговорюють у профільних комітетах Верховної Ради.
Це може стати цікавим революційним кроком.
Супутник визначає, що почалося, далі ми бачимо, на якій земельній ділянці, хто є користувачем.
Відповідно він далі має пояснити, чому це відбулося.
Це випадковість? Мовляв, блискавка вдарила?
Чи навмисний підпал? Далі це не можна приховати.
Проте - з електронними протоколами чи без - невирішеною досі залишиться
головна проблема: куди дівати опале листя чи сільгоспвідходи.
Системи централізованого вивезення цього немає, а платити за це, як за звичайне сміття, селяни не хочуть.
Деякі підприємства, які займаються виробництвом екологічних добрив,
починають пропонувати селянам здавати відходи безкоштовно, як ось це підприємство з виробництва біогумусу в Борисполі.
Ось готовий біогумус. Це бур'яни, те, що люди палять.
Ось що з цього виходить. Ми готові приймати - аби лише вони не палили листя чи городину.
Над культурою такого вивезення, каже підприємець, ще треба працювати.
Адже люди нерідко разом із сіном привозять інше сміття.
Ось таке завозять. Зверху ніби нормальне, а ось! Черв’яки ж таке не їдять!
А загалом, каже Олександр, робити компост люди можуть самі на власних ділянках.
Це дозволить їм не витрачатися на хімічні добрива і вирощувати екологічно чисті продукти.
Про це мріють і активісти з Хотіва.
Ми розуміємо, що зміни не відбудуться за один сезон.
Тобто ми вивезли все, що могли вивезти, і закінчили на цьому. Ні!
Ця зміна в мізках, вона відбувається довго,
щоб люди розуміли, що палити - це ненормально.
Що змушувати інших людей дихати брудним повітрям
- це ненормально, є й інше рішення цієї проблеми.
Анастасія з однодумцями сподіваться, що зможуть досягти більшого
вже наступного року, коли в Хотіві буде створена ОТГ і у громади
з’явиться більше інструментів впливу на владу і спільний бюджет.